rein in den corona herbst und da hören
wir dass die masken pflicht in vollem
umfang wieder zurückkehren soll in alle
innenräume von oktober bis ostern von
oktober bis ostern wirklich herr
lauterbach viele menschen machen das
nicht mehr mit wie auch er hier den
kennen sie ein bekannter schlager sänger
aus deutschland auf der bühne
[Musik]
sie sind los
toner 569 könnten aufwendig grunde ist
alles vorbei das geht mir auf den sack
und ist kein arschloch
insel in brand steckten
werner bringt der schlagersänger hier
auf der waldbühne in berlin da einmal
groß auf holt auch mit der korona
politik und gegen karl lauterbach
schießt drückt das die stimmung im land
im moment ganz gut aus vor preißler wenn
wir über neue massnahmen richtung herbst
sprechen
ich denke es drückt die stimmung sehr
gut aus weil sie so losgelöst vom
infektionsgeschehen geführt wird also
sie haben ja schon angeht dieser sie
haben gesagt von oktober bis ostern
was ich sehr unlogisch finden denn
eigentlich müsste es heißen von oktober
bis ostern
sofern die infektions lage ist notwendig
macht denn ich finde es immer
übergriffig wenn etwas entschieden wird
ohne dass es dafür gute gründe gibt und
wir müssten eigentlich aus der
vergangenheit gelernt haben dass also
maßnahmen die nicht einleuchten sind
zu frust führen also bei mir zu wasser
in mecklenburg verbrannt gab es eine
ausgangssperre und wenn ich nachts aus
dem haus gehe muss ich sowieso schon
ganz schön weit laufen überhaupt noch
jemanden zu finden also warum ich dann
durch eine ausgangssperre von einem
infektionsgeschehen geschützt werden
muss das leuchtet mir nicht ein und wenn
es nicht einleuchtet gibt es krawall
stehen sie herrn bringt einmal auf der
bühne sein frust raus lässt sich sagt
das geht uns offen sagt ja ich habe mich
der einzige der den frust rausgelassen
hat was eben nicht funktioniert sind
nicht evidenzbasierte und nicht der
entsprechende situation angepasste
maßnahmen ja ich meine wenn
schleswig-holstein nichts los ist und in
bayern die luft brennt wegen krone da
fragt man sich ja auch warum wird man im
bild fleisch oder woanders okay das ist
jetzt ob sie recht darauf sich masken
pflicht da waren wenn nämlich gerade
aber das wt1 basiert das ist ja die
debatte des wochenendes jahr angezettelt
unter anderem noch mal durch marco
buschmann der eigene harmlosen satz
gesagt hat im zeitungsinterview ehrlich
gesagt hat das brauchen wir nur dann
wenn das wirklich nützlich an dass in
der punkt ist noch nicht gestellt
basiert nicht verhältnismäßig viele
angemessen ist weder notwendig noch ist
es im engeren sinne verhältnis mit es
macht ja keinen sinn die ganze zeit tun
es ist kalender abhängig und das ist
nicht auch den den pandemie wellen
angepasst also man muss jetzt wirklich
nachdenken was man im herbst machen will
das ist richtig machen stufenplan aber
das kann man auch über die mast
nachdenken aber nur eins ja auch ein
bisschen vor
zur
einzuordnen man hat ja vom kanzleramt
nicht gesagt man macht dass man hat
gesagt man denkt darüber nach also ist
er
genauso wenig kommt ja aber es wäre
unvernünftig dass ein kalender
anzubinden und nicht an den
entsprechenden situation wie handhaben
sie dass frau putzen tragen sie noch
wenn ich fragen darf maske zum beispiel
im supermarkt da ist es immer so eine
spaltung wie ich das noch erleben die
einen seit wochen mittlerweile ohne ganz
viele aber weiter konsequent mit maske
wie handhaben sie das also so an sich
die kaum noch selber einkaufen also ich
lasse das alles erledigen und nicht
gegen sich auch nicht mehr
großartig raus am anfang also als es
dann hieß masken pflicht fällt weg habe
ich natürlich gemacht einfach um mich
selber zu schützen also
gar nicht großartig um irgendwie jetzt
andere zu schützen sondern einfach weil
ich in meinem zustand nicht noch mit
irgendwas krank werden wollte sei es
jetzt corona oder erkältung aber
mittlerweile weil ich halt diese luft
probleme habe mache ich auch nicht mehr
haben sie den eindruck haben wir haben
überhaupt ernsthaft die wahl also am
supermarkt vorne steht weiter die
empfehlung drauf karl lauterbach sagte
letzt am freitag dringende empfehlung
bitte maske tragen obwohl wir keine
masken pflicht haben ist das eine völlig
freie entscheidung im moment also freier
als sie die impfung war das würde ich
schon sagen das erlebe ich tatsächlich
auch so dass menschen sich am anfang
sehr zögerlich aber jetzt würde ich
sagen also die mehrheit deutliche
mehrheit trägt eben keine maske mehr und
zu dem was sie gerade sagten also die
frage masken pflicht das dass das
scheint dass es so ein grundproblem
dieser corona politik dass man mit
bürgern und bürgerinnen spricht als
wären sie ungünstig ja man möchte ihnen
zügel anziehen sie uns vorher eben
gesagt diesen erzieherischen gedanken
warum denn eine pflicht warum denn keine
empfehlung denn eine gut sitzende maske
die man wie man richtig trägt daran
scheitern ja schon aber ihre fdp trägt
das am ende mit wieder da wird irgendwie
klar sie oder am ende unterschreibt der
lindner oder abwarten meinen lieben ich
bin nämlich der festen überzeugung dass
also masten tatsächlich
schützen und ich trage sie wirklich
gerne und ich trage sie sitzen und dann
können sie alle machen was sie wollen
wenn sie finden sie können ohne maske
einkaufen gehen einfach standen ich
bringe dann die einkäufe wenn sie in
fünf tagen alle krank sind aber ich
denke die fdp hat gerade in den
vergangenen monaten richtig guten job
gemacht und sie hat uns vor der
allgemeinen pflicht bewahrt und sie wird
weiter aufklären und informieren und ich
finde er
hat das gemacht ist dafür massiv erhöht
worden verbal auch aus den eigenen
reihen ist dass das kann ja gut ab diese
klappe aber ich muss ihnen auch sagen
dass wir
der meinung sind denke ich in der fdp
dass die impfungen gut ist aber die
impfentscheidung in frei sein sollte und
wäre gilt auch für die einrichtungs
bezirk muss es nur mal noch erwähnen
weil das land jetzt noch ganz oft
gesehen aber da ist ja der hsv zumindest
daran im pflicht kommt nicht das ist er
uns verlässt aber jetzt machen werde
streitbarsten pflicht an spricht ja
verliert völlig aus dem gesichtsfeld wo
wir jetzt uns befinden also wir sind
sommer niedriger infektion zur geringe
infektions wahrscheinlichkeit und dann
noch zu empfehlen dass ich jetzt jeder
den vierten buchstaben seien also hin
und herschwanken einer sommerwetter ist
ja sagt ja aber sie wollen einstieg
empfehlen genau vor werde ich jetzt wir
jetzt in vielen vierten booster zu
nehmen heißt es heißt dass man den
empfiehlt auf den fünften zu nehmen
damit ich mich jetzt impfen das würde
ich mit über 60 dann würde ich mich im
herbst noch mal impfen lassen müssen
weil natürlich ein spätes aber das ist
ja interessant
70-prozentige besseren schutz gegen die
infect das uns interessant herr
lauterbach spricht genau sie an er meint
genau sie in der pressekonferenz vom
freitag er meint genau ihre altersgruppe
er meint genau jemanden der wie sie zum
beispiel hier in dieser talkshow wieder
mal viele kontakte hat er meint genau
sie und er in vielen an jetzt lassen sie
sich bewusst ich habe schon
untergegangen
und jetzt sitzt der trotzige der bockige
klaus stöhr sitzt hier und sagt herr
lauterbach das mache ich gar nicht
ähnlich hier ich habe zwar etwas aber
dort ein breites kreuz macht nicht wer
das wichtiger ist welche kommunikation
bei den menschen ankommt eben nicht so
viel ahnung vom thema haben wie ich
davon ab und schauen sie mal im februar
märz april war unser gesundheitssystem
nicht überlastet gewesen großflächig und
da war noch viel weniger menschen
geimpft war viel weniger menschen
infiziert und warum spreche ich dann
jetzt im herbst profil mehr menschen da
noch geschützt sind darüber dass ich
jetzt schon masken tragen möchte wenn im
prinzip die situation sich
höchstwahrscheinlich noch weiter
entschärfen will also man setzt ein
völlig falsches signal man
kompromittiert gleich auch eine gute
maßnahme meisten helfen ja auch mal
kompromittiert diese maßnahme jetzt in
dem man schon wieder feuer feuer ruft
und im herbst wird dann keiner mehr
darauf was hat das mit ihnen gemacht
frau preißler am freitag wie der
pressekonferenz die ganze woche die karl
lauterbach von sommer welle spricht
übrigens nachdem er wenige wochen vorher
noch gesagt hat die sommer welle wird
nicht gefährlich werden jetzt kommt die
sommer wenn er schränkt zwar ein ja ja
erst aber trotzdem dieses wort macht ja
mit einem was sommer welle was macht es
mit ihnen ich finde das ganz interessant
dass sie auch schon differenzieren
zwischen dem den umständen und der
wortwahl weil tatsächlich haben wir
einen sommer werde ich kenne unfassbar
viele leute um mich herum die gerade
eben an krone erkrankt sind also wir
können die fakten nicht leugnen kroner
ist arkona passiert und die leute werden
krank und haben unterschiedlich schwere
verläufe dass sie entscheiden und auch
die schmerzen nur oder ich bin keine
medizinerin deswegen sage ich dazu auch
nichts aber ich finde die sprache macht
enorm was dann tatsächlich dieses
ständige feuer feuer feuer feuer rufen
bringt und dazu dass wir irgendwann
schon zur neuro ene auf durchzug
schalten müssen weil wir einfach nur
einen gewissen anteil an warnungen
schlechten botschaften aushalten können
denn wir haben wir müssen eben unser
leben meistern und deswegen glaube ich
auch dass also
die beratung oder seine beratung
vielleicht nicht die beste ist denn
dieses nachts twittern und alarm alarm
und eine pressekonferenz ich wünschte
mir tatsächlich von meinem minister dass
er immer mehr im ministerium ist auch
noch mehr themen beleuchtet also diese
sehr
diese diskutieren jetzt über eine maske
schlecht ist müssen wir auch weil es
steht ja zu befürchten dass die
irgendeine art und weise kommen
eigentlich müssen wir auch über exit
strategien sprechen wir müssen darüber
sprechen wie wir wieder zu einem
normalzustand kommt denn wenn wir jetzt
mit einer allgemein masken pflicht im
herbst weitermachen werden wir sie nicht
mehr los na ja ich stelle mich nicht
mehr ökologie schokolade ullmann hat im
wörther 2020 gesagt wir könnten doch da
war ja auch impfungen hat gerade erst
angefangen und so weiter die asl regel
die könnte man doch im winter immer
machen und zwar im dezember zweiter das
ist einfach das ist das ist doch ein
interessanter punkt das heißt
mittlerweile sagte lauterbach naja
masken schlecht wenn wir die halt da
haben dann im herbst von o bis o also
von oktober bis ostern dann schützt auch
vor anderen schweren infektionen aus
dann haben wir das vr stört dann schützt
es eben auch von einem von der sonstigen
grippe von erkältung vielleicht auch
voller magen darm infektes ist
verhältnismäßig ist die fragen und
empfand habe er seine 370 stimmen im
bundestag mehr so sein herz marie hat
sich nochmal ich schreibe ist das ist
eine juristische frage wer erklärt jetzt
die verhältnismäßigkeit da sagt die
bundesregierung immer weiter haben wir
keine zahlen zu ich kann ihnen auch
nicht sagen das ist die englische sun
lewis kennen für jemand der im prinzip
nicht so zu steuern ist für jemand der
als bundesminister egal wo er sitzt
kommuniziert würde ich mehr
bodenständigkeit
verantwortungsbewusstsein strategie
langfristiges denken erhoffen und mehr
auch eine bessere vorbereitung denn
nicht nur pressekonferenz geben sagt
keine panik sondern redet nicht so
schlimm aber vielleicht wenn man ruhig
und sommer haben will sollte man sie
vielleicht impfen lassen aber vielleicht
nur die über aber da ich jemand was war
dann zu schauen alle noch einmal konkret
herrschte was muss gegeben sein damit
auch sie sagen würden im herbst brauchen
wir tatsächlich masken pflicht also was
wäre die entsprechende evidenz dafür ja
man brauche jetzt ein stufenplan da
hätte parameter die wichtigsten
parameter würden seien
krankenhauseinweisungen kann muss
bewegung und intensivstation belegung
und diese parameter würde man bin dann
bestimmte situationen weil 15% 20% 15%
und dann würde man bestimmte maßnahmen
dann wie sie jetzt aktuell dort aus also
blick einmal ganz schnell lief sagt
heuser in berlin liegen weniger als 40
leute auf einer intensivstation lenkt
oder in deutschland ist relativ hohe man
kann so wie man sich nur hoffen kann für
ein sommer aber noch mal brauchen stufen
plant er jetzt transparent auch mit der
gewiss nicht immer positiv agenda für
den herbst den leuten zeigt was gemacht
werden müsste wenn das allgemeinwohl
belastet also wenn die gesundheit wenn
die krankenhäuser nicht mehr so
weitermachen könnten wenn dieser stufen
plan vorlegt dann müsste man auch genau
wann dieser maßnahmen wieder abgebaut
werden würden interessant ist dass es in
vielen anderen ländern so überhaupt
nicht diskutiert wird wie in diesem das
eigentlich man entspannt den sommer
genießt einfach dass man auch richtung
herbst in spanien in portugal selbst und
die zahlen hoch gegangen sind recht
entspannt richtung herbst schaut und
nicht über neue masken pflicht über neue
massnahmen diskutiert warum es gibt also
es ist es ist irgendwie es ist eine art
obsession ich kann es mir nicht anders
erklären und sie entkoppelt sich auch
völlig von der realität jensen endes das
ist das grundproblem was wir haben und
zum thema verhältnismäßigkeit ist
unterstellt evidenz also auch auf
also nicht nur individuell sondern eben
auch auf die ganze gesellschaft bezogen
angenommen es gibt eine entsprechende
evidenz für die massen wieder muss man
sich trotzdem die frage stellen ist das
verhältnismässig ist das und das ist
eine rein juristische frage jetzt
erstmal die zuallererst die der
gesetzgeber zu beantworten hat denn er
entscheidet sich wie es rechtlich löst
oder wie es gesetzlich löst oder nicht
und danach ist in die gerichte an der
dran und müssen dann überprüfen ist
immer das licht aus ihrer sicht aus
ihrer juristischen sicht aktuell noch
verhältnissen meines erachtens ist sie
in der also eine allgemeine masken krieg
für die für die bevölkerung im
allgemeinen die ist nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig möglich sein auch nicht
in bus und bahn sind quadratisch sind
genau und zwar aus folgendem grund etwas
anderes gilt für wunder einrichtungen
aber bei warum ist sie nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig die maske wenn sie jeder
hat die möglichkeit sich selbst zu
schützen mit impfungen maske abstand
halten sonstiges es gibt
behandlungsmöglichkeit so das heißt wir
haben ein lebensrisiko eines mehr es
gibt viele anderen auch das heißt wir
müssen sind jetzt in der situation wo
wir individuell mit diesen lebensrisiko
umgehen müssen und auch
zwischenmenschlich sinnvoll wenn ich
jetzt weiß ich bin in der gruppe wohl
oder älter menschen sind und wir sind im
innenraum teste ich mich natürlich
vorher ja das ist sinnvoll aber da
brauche ich kein staat er mir das sagt
und auch die maske da brauche ich auch
keinen staat er mir da sie nicken herr
stört das heißt sie würden auch sagen
mit blick auf die nächsten monate
supermarkt sowieso nicht evidenzbasiert
braucht man nicht öffentliche
verkehrsmittel auch keine reserven auch
evidenz mit verhältnismäßigkeit evidenz
seite kann ich jetzt nicht so viel wie
genau aber verhältnismäßigkeit der
eigenverantwortung auch extrem wichtig
denn sie hat schon ganz großartig gesagt
wenn sie irgendwo hingeht wo er sich
aufhalten
testen sie sich vorher v hat und so sehe
ich das mit der maske auch wenn wir uns
weiter im supermarkt treffen trage ich
nur masken sie nicht ich finde ich ok
einverstanden für mich ist die masse des
masten tragen im sommer die verlängerung
zum ende so anthony wir werden uns ja
alle infizieren das ist ja völlig
fraglos es ist schlechterdings nicht
möglich vor dem virus sich zu verstecken
es wird passieren und wir haben ein
stabiles gesundheitswesen wir haben
impfstoff mit nebenwirkung und es gibt
gute medikamente viel besser als mir
erhoffen konnte und jetzt wird sich
jeder infizieren und wer jetzt die
infektion noch nach hinten schiebt
nachdem er sich hoffentlich geimpft hat
schiebt auch in dem ihm denn nach hinten
also wer jetzt auch diese infektion
nicht zulässt verschiebt diese infektion
in dem herbst etwas
umständlich oder männern die prävalenz
sich auch verlängert dann ist es so
vielen gruppen sogar gefährlichen
sterben gegebenen fall müsste sich herr
müller punkten auch selber schützen
sollen die auf eigenverantwortliche
handeln müssen herrschte ein zitat da
starte ich habe ich die verantwortung
ich finde es ja auch nicht schlecht weil
sie haben ein auto braucht man in der
pressekonferenz jetzt vorgeschlagen dass
man in den altenpflegeheimen
verpflichtend hygiene beauftragte
einsetzt dann hätte man vor 82 jahren
meyer 40 prozent der todesfälle in den
letzten zwei jahren waren gab es in den
altenpflege einrichtung nicht bei den
nicht bei den kindern und da hat man mit
dem rasenmäher prinzip hat man alle
gleich behandelt und die hat man
vergessen dass man das jetzt richtig
macht finde ich gut zum beispiel aber
wenn man jetzt die infektion nach hinten
schiebt dann gibt es natürlich
infektionen die aktuellen cupid führen
da gibt es auch schwerer erkranken da
wird gibt's todesfälle aber ist es so
als diese die ich sage mal die fläche
unter der kurve ist gleich die spitz
sein
und kurz oder lang und flach aber die
leute die erkranken und sterben werden
werden die anzahl dieser eben leider das
ist bei so einem viera tor-phänomen zu
haben über die massen pflicht diskutiert
hier in dieser runde wir haben über die
impfung diskutiert und wir haben das
auch mit verputzen getan an diesem tisch
die nachricht vor wie sie sagte unter
den folgen dieser letzten impfung vor
allem zu leiden hat wann hoffen sie wann
glauben sie wann rechnen sie damit
wieder voll bei kräften zu sein und
tatsächlich auch ihren leistungssport
ihren dreikampf wieder voll ausüben zu
können ich hoffe dass ich dieses jahr
auf jeden fall noch wettkämpfe machen
kann weil ansonsten bin ich erst mal
raus denke ich aus dem nationalkader
aber da man ja auch kein arzt sagen kann
was in meinem körper ab geht und welche
behandlung helfen kann ich leider nur
abwarten deutsche meisterin nämlich die
hoffentlich bald wieder ihren titel
verteidigen kann wieder gewinnen kann
und möglicherweise noch nach höherem
streben kann vielen dank frau putzen